y más tarde
identidad
en la casa esta mañana me preguntaron de
qué va a hablar de identidad y maruja
dijo y tú qué sabes de identidad de sé
de cacao venezolano
el mapa de venezuela como lo ven en esta
foto y como lo ven dentro de su corazón
es así por el cacao
la forma que tiene por las rutas de
salida del cacao cuando en 1607
salió el primer barco cargado con esta
semilla
ese mapa cambio y en el mundo entero no
se habló más de venezuela se hablaba de
maracaibo sur del lago
puerto cabello carenero cumaná carúpano
río caribe y cuando vayan a alemania van
a ir a una chocolatería que se llama
puerto cabello y cuando vayan a japón
van a ir a una chocolatería que se llama
cal en ello'
porque así venían los sacos marcados de
esa ruta de salida del cacao
ese mapa cambió completamente porque
vaya a ver si le digo bien
desde suya
incluyendo margaritas y desde caracas
hasta más zonas venezuela está bendita
por una cruz de cacao no hay un solo
pedazo de este territorio que no esté
bendecido por el cacao eso hace que
tenemos la diversidad más fantástica del
planeta que si es que acaba de venezuela
es el mejor del mundo no son miles de
cacao de venezuela que fueron por
cuatrocientos años los mejores del mundo
y que nos toca ahora volverlos a poner
en todas las bombonerías en todas las
tiendas de chocolate porque hoy en día
parece un mito el cacao de venezuela hay
gente que dice que no existe porque no
llega por las dos aduanas convencionales
otros dicen que es impagable hay otros
que dicen que es de colombia hay otros
que dicen que es de perú como los
pequeños y las arepas entonces cuando
hablamos de identidad yo les podría
decir que en venezuela
somos cacao
se acuerdan del mapa que tenemos al lado
derecho de mi izquierdo de ustedes
también así
julia y toda la región occidental
hablamos de zulia de mérida de táchira
de trujillo y allí nacieron los cacaos
criollos qué quiere decir que acá los
criollos los cacaos que como los hijos
de los españoles conquistadores nacieron
en esta tierra todo lo que había nacido
aquí era criollo los demás los museos
como jill eran los forasteros entonces
en toda esta parte occidental los cacaos
son de semilla blanca los forasteros que
si compartimos con otros países con
colombia podemos ver el mapa completo
venezuela colombia ecuador perú bolivia
y brasil son cacao de semilla oscura
forastero museo de los que no nacieron
aquí los extranjeros
esos pecados se unen en el delta del
orinoco y sacan de nosotros lo mejor
aquí tenemos los cacaos venezolanos
todas las formas todos los colores todos
los bonitos todos los feos juntos cuando
usted va a una plantación de cacao
venezolano es como lo que yo estoy
viendo desde aquí blancos morenos
negritos colorados azules rosados esos
somos nosotros por el cacao entonces
recordemos cacao indígenas
febres-cordero nos dice que nuestros
indígenas tomaban chorotes quien es
mexicano aquí no inventaron miel
chocolate ni nació en méxico nació en
venezuela la primera planta de cacao en
la sierra de perija cacao guasare
este cacao que está ahí como arrugadito
en mi colegio y en mi carro de origen me
dicen la profesora guasare
estos pecados criollos que fueron
famosos en el mundo tienen nariz
como lo ven allí tienen cuello como lo
ven arriba generalmente son amarillos
verdes y hay algunos que tienen un velo
blanco que recuerda la porcelana china
porque es así como translúcido y por eso
le pusieron a los cacaos del sur del
lago de maracaibo porcelana así que si
usted ve un cacao porcelana de piura o
de eso conozco levante la mano y diga
los pequeños son de los teques y el
porcelana es de venezuela
esos pecados blancos no solo su música
sino su semilla
miren qué belleza
porque son blancos porque no tienen
taninos y al no tener caminos no son
amargos entonces se le conoció en la
historia como los cacaos dulces de
venezuela de caracas de puerto cabello
de canoabo de choroní de chuao cuyagua
con botox pp y todas las playas de
aragua esos cacaos se vendían más caro
porque no necesitaban azúcar para ser
sabrosos y los papás y los cardenales y
las monjas adictos a algunas cosas pero
siempre al chocolate decían que no se
quebrantaba el ayuno si se como si se
tomaba chocolate sin azúcar en ese
momento venezuela elevó los precios
hasta el día de hoy y no hay todavía en
el 2008 un cacao que se precie más que
el cacao de hecho
todas esas características si hablamos
de órgano leche podríamos decir que
tienen sabores dulces nobles elegantes
y a quien describe a los venezolanos
dulces nobles elegantes buena moza buena
mossos honestos e imborrables en la
memoria colectiva un venezolano no se le
olvida a nadie como el cacao criollo del
otro lado aquellos forasteros que
también nos pertenecen se les dijo que
eran amargos que eran muy gordos pero
muy robustos que no servían sino para la
industria porque daban buen licor buena
manteca y buen polvo de cacao esos que
acabamos ponían 10 por ciento en los
chocolates del mundo y daban todos los
aromas que se podía esperar cuál es la
receta de todo porque es todo 10 más
rico en venezuela porque lleva en
porcentaje secreto
un poquito de sur del lago más de
carnero y un toque de río caribe en
ninguna otra parte del mundo hay tres
tipos de cacao están distintos para
hacer ese polvo
entonces eso es que acá vos
bastaría hacer por cada pueblo por cada
río por cada playa una tableta de
chocolate para entender el tamaño de la
biodiversidad que acabo que hay en
venezuela
eso que acabas tienen esas semillas
llenas de taninos son muy fuertes muy
aromáticos pero como los venezolanos
se enamoraron
criollo y forasteros y dieron un tercer
cacao como se llama este tercer cacao se
vale que pregunte
como no es el primero el más rico
no
trinitario
pero parte de nuestra identidad es que
esos cacaos se conocieron en el delta
del orinoco los criollos recorrieron el
mapa por toda la costa de venezuela
llegaron a perú por toda la cordillera
andina llegaron a méxico por todo
centroamérica y los forasteros llegaron
al delta por el orín o entonces el
verdadero nombre de esos cabos del tano
o paria no pero se lo llevaron a la isla
de trinidad y ninguno de nosotros salió
decir es para ese que acaba es nuestro
se quedó como trinitario pero este cacao
es tan bonito como cualquier venezolano
une todo lo de una mamá blanca con todo
lo de un papa negro les suena
entonces tenemos indígenas que
comerciaban con cacao españoles que
descubrieron árboles días salvajes de
cacao pero por supuesto se casaron con
los indígenas y cómo no era suficiente
todo el cacao que salía de este
territorio para los mercados europeos
trajeron la mano de obra canaria y por
eso muchos de nosotros tenemos
tatarabuelos canarios y los ojos rayados
pero como tampoco fueron suficientes
trajeron esclavos de áfrica entonces a
ustedes se pueden imaginar esa
plantación de cacao de venezuela llena
de todos los colores con gente que fue
la primera
identidad global del planeta que si
teníamos identidad o no teníamos la
teníamos todas como nuestra mesa que
suma ingredientes de todos los
continentes para hacer un plato
venezolano como nuestra música que suma
todos los ritmos indígenas africanos
españoles cuando nosotros comemos un
chocolate elaborado con cacao de chuao
suenan las maracas indígenas
suenan los tambores regios de áfrica y
cantan los ángeles en las iglesias
católicas eso es lo que hace que el
chocolate venezolano sea complejo
álvaro gómez diría
que una maraca de cacao venezolano lleva
adentro nuestro adn o que nosotros somos
cacao y que sobre un fondo suave de
chocolate hay mucho hay brisa marina hay
brisa de la montaña rocío de la mañana
hay no es esa y frutas hay barcos y hay
que acabar pesaban en oriente a todo lo
que sabe paria madera tabaco café
selva playa montaña otros saben a todas
las nueces otros si ustedes piensan en
barlovento mango guayaba parchita
entonces podemos decir otra vez que los
venezolanos somos complejos como el
cacao y aquí no queda ni un solo
fermentación venezuela primer país que
fermento cacao dicen los libros antiguos
que en venezuela se metía el que acabó
bajo la tierra para protegerlo del moho
que se sacaba y se pasaba por jugo de
naranja cajera para que aguantará el
viaje en los barcos imagínense todo el
mundo lleno de semillas de cacao no ven
cómo se repite la historia todo el mundo
oli está lleno de venezolanos cambiando
el planeta queríamos cambiar el país si
ahora vamos a cambiar el mundo es un
momento maravilloso es un momento lleno
de creatividad es un momento en que la
lucha es trabajar
y como me queda poquito tiempo le voy a
pasar un vídeo
y los voy a dejar con esta imagen la
iglesia de chuao que la conocen en todos
los lugares del mundo
[Aplausos]
[Música]